Wallace directed by John Hill code from
a script by Nick Cave based on a book by
Matt ponderin it's the story of three
brothers in their life and their love
and their family during Prohibition
involved in the countryside of West
Virginia the mountains of West Virginia
in a very tough time in a very
particular time in America considering
this special deputies well they tried to
put rules regulations on some of them
contains a report of legal reasons for
moral reasons and you can't contain them
let's work it out so everybody can do
some business out of that comes guys
that are gonna keep on doing what
they've always done which is essentially
making a living and you also get the
organized crime coming up you get you
know institutionalized organized crime
you know we give the police the feds and
also criminals getting more organized to
get their supply routes I'm the one
who's going to make your life feel
difficult from now on if you don't talk
the lion country boy so it's a
fascinating moment in America's history
and I think you're looking at a lot of
things changing there the FBI comes in
bigger cars the wire that's the
telephone you know it's one of those
almost the last the last days of the
Wild West in America
I wouldn't visited the family who the
book was based on their relatives hung
out in West Virginia and then we
rehearsed it with Nick you know I'm with
John and with the other actors in the
space and you um you don't even it could
play some music for us you know and we'd
never think about something we'd sit
there and and you basically start to
come up and feel it and then Nick would
respond to the actors as well and and
maybe find their maybe with certain
passages of dialogue or just fine you
know tuned a little bit more
any subject John's a very particular guy
you know I think he's a very very
soft-spoken and very gentle and all that
but he's this this there's a lot of
method behind his madness you should
never have left us brother hang on Mikey
come Christmas Day one I know why you've
come back John
Nick right the proposition to kill me
brother I want you to kill your brother
he wrote this one as well I love Barbara
we don't lay down for me buddy Nick it's
just I mean it's very similar to John
he's got he's got a very particular
idiosyncratic vegan and um and way of
listening to the world and seeing
moments or pieces which has come from a
lifetime of experience I feel these easy
zone man you know he's at his own
creative confident open spirit as is
John know love us turkey loves and
family a very good couple
but one of my friends wanted to know
like feet but just let me know what he's
wearing
you know because you looks always in the
three-piece suit so I thought we're in
the middle of them with it you know with
some little little place in Georgia
love the Georgia she played of it but
when some little place at a little
rehearsal hall and I thought I wonder
what Nick Cave is wearing so I walk in
there and there is in the three-piece
suit in the middle in the middle of
Georgia in the middle of summer
sweltering heat in a dirty little
rehearsal space Nick's got the UM you
know that the two-tone leather shoes the
pants the belt the white shirt the best
and the jacket and it was just like
hahaha sent a photo to my friends back
at sitting they said yeah of course of
course cave and be wearing the same
thing